[Music]
so
[Music]
hello my name is cecil slipovic and i'm
musician in residence at yale
university's
fortune of video archive for holocaust
testimonies
this video series is designed as a
companion to our album
where is our homeland which is the first
volume in the archives ongoing effort
to present songs and poems performed by
survivors in testimonies given to the
fortune of archive
over the last 40 years you can learn
more about the project on the archives
website
songs from testimonies.org
where is our homeland songs from
testimonies volume 1
was recorded in 2019 by the cecil
slupovich ensemble
featuring renowned singer sasha luria
craig udelman on the violin joshua camp
on the accordion
keyboards and guitar dmitry ischenko on
the base
and myself on woodwinds the songs in
this collection differ vastly in terms
of style
social and historical background
language and many other aspects
but collectively they create a
multi-dimensional picture
of jewish life before and during world
war
ii this song
that we're going to talk about and
listen to
today was the song of the plush of
inmates it was
sung or rather recited as a poem
by ruth c a native of krakov
poland where she was born in 1920.
during the holocaust ruth survived
several labor camps
and concentration camps in both her
native country
and in germany the inmates
wrote this poem they were quietly
passing it
on to each other as a mean of hope
for survival as a hope to escape
from the deadly cemetery gate
as the song goes
[Music]
here
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
brown
[Music]
[Music]
is
the lyrics of this hymn were related by
a survivor
of the poishuv concentration camp named
ruth cohen
who believes it was written by one of
her fellow inmates
it speaks to the terrible feeling that
prisoners felt at roll call
or oppo plots every morning at 5 am in
the camp
when the prisoners lined up and felt as
if they are one step away from death
the notorious camp commander amon gut
who was portrayed by the actor ray
fines in the film schindler's list would
sometimes
randomly shoot the prisoners at whim
during these roll calls
pashov represented more than the deaths
of individuals
poisson represented the death of the
krakow jewish community
so by thinking about the krakow jewish
community before the holocaust
we can better appreciate the immensity
of the loss
krakow had been a major religious center
throughout the early modern period it
was home
to several lean rabbinical figures such
as
rabbi moses israelis mordechai jaffe
the old circus the visitor to krakow
today
can still see the old synagogues
testament to its former glory the old
jewish cemetery
but by the interwar period krakow jewry
had become much more diverse
krakow was home to theaters cabarets
literary cafes
the great folk song writer mordechai
gueberte
who lived in krakow wrote the song is
brent our town is burning
a defiant song calling on the jews
to rise up and defend themselves during
the pogroms late 1930s
krakow was also home to many hasidic
jews
followers of the great bubba rebbe and
the belzer rebbe
and it was home to a teachers seminary
to train
teachers for orthodox and hasidic girls
and women
krakow was also a major zionist center
and this was the affiliation of ruth
cohen and her family
the great rabbi oziah stone preached
in the temple synagogue and was a
fervent zionist
this same or parliament deputy a
pulinary heart glass
was also a zionist and lived in krakow
in the wake of world war one during the
pogroms that occurred in krakow
the zionists were absolutely crucial to
the formation
of jewish self-defense units
and after this they formed a major
newspaper novogenic which had a
circulation of around 15 000.
zionists held about half the seats on
the kehillah
or the jewish communal self-government
the other half was was held by
hasidic and assimilationist jews there
was also a very popular zionist youth
group named akiva
which would perform a major role
in self-defense during the holocaust
ruth cohen describes her upbringing in
krakow
as occurring between two worlds one
polish
one hebrew ruth attended the zionist
gymnasium where they would learn study
in polish half the day in hebrew the
other half of the day
she thought of herself as really a
zionist
but her family did not have any thoughts
immigrating
to palestine they tried to escape when
the war broke out
but it was just too late
first they lived in the krakow ghetto
and then
on march 13th they were deported along
with most of krakow jews
to the poacher of concentration camp and
by this time there were about 20 000
jews
who were prisoners there and the camp
was run by the notorious
among the sadistic ss commandant
oscar schindler's enamel factory was
located adjacent to the camp
goat and the other guards shot thousands
of jews
and deported thousands more to their
deaths
in auschwitz according to ruth
everyone was afraid all the time but
especially terrified
at 5 00 5 am in the morning when they
would line
up for roll call appel plots
the song the hymn of quasho
reads as follows every morning at 5 the
trumpet wakes us
up with its familiar call to the appa
plots
we stand in straight rows if a hand were
to signal the distance
we would all escape as soon as possible
from the cemetery gate
dark knight hovers over the roofs the
city is sound asleep
only we just one more step and the heart
will die in pain it's especially
poignant to compare this song
to the pre-war song by gabertag is brent
our town is barney
which urged the jews to rise up against
their persecutors
and fight and certainly during the
holocaust
members of the youth group akiva did
just that
however a more representative feeling
is probably captured in this song a
feeling of despair
a feeling of terror a longing for escape
that rarely occurred
[Music]
you